it's famed for being one of china's
furnace cities with the longer summers
and hottest temperatures
but in the last couple of months the
heat in the southwestern city of
chongqing has been oppressive even by
its own standards
mercury levels have frequently topped 40
degrees celsius and hit an all-time
record high of 45 degrees earlier this
week
yeah it's hot as hell i'm melting
many tourists come to chongqing to
marvel at its sights the tialing river
might be what's most eye-catching now
it's a major tributary that meets the
yangtze further south and it's dried up
so much people can walk halfway across
it
i'm definitely worried it could affect
residents and those that need to use the
water
forecasters have warned the dry spell
could last well into september
authorities have begun discharging water
from the three gorges dam to replenish
the yangtze and its offshoots
but normal flows could still be months
away
here in the city people are cooling off
wherever possible
this library converted out of an old air
raid shelter has become a popular
hangout
a breeze circulates through the
funnel-shaped space making it an ideal
hideaway
when it's especially hot more people
come
but elsewhere it's hard to escape the
effects of this heatwave and the drought
that's come with it
a short drive south of the city is
longjing village with insufficient
irrigation crops here are dying well
this here shows pretty clearly why crops
are struggling the water for this field
behind us has receded about 20 meters
away from the crops and what's been left
behind is just this bone-dry layer of
mud
reports say more than 350 000 people in
rural chongqing are suffering because of
a shortage of water supplies
many of them like one man we spoke to
are elderly and can't do much to fix the
problem
for irrigation systems you have to buy
pipes and machines you have to spend the
money and it's not worth it because the
stuff has already dried and died what's
the point of watering if it's already
dead
and with many scientists saying hotter
days as a result of global warming are
here to stay
days here for the people of longing
could be numbered patrick fox al jazeera
chongqing china